>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
ONE UPSIDE OF A VERY SAD WAR IN
UKRAINE IS A NATIONAL
CONVERSATION IN THIS COUNTRY
ABOUT FREEDOM AND DEMOCRACY.
THOSE ARE WORDS ON EVERYONE'S
LIPS.
AND SO IT SET US OFF ON A
NATIONWIDE SEARCH FOR AMERICANS
WHO ARE LIVING AS IF THIS WERE A
FREE COUNTRY LIKE, SAY, IT WAS
1989.
ONE OF THE FIRST PEOPLE WE FOUND
WAS KID ROCK.
SPENT THE WEEKEND INTERVIEWING
HIM IN JUST A MOMENT.
JUST WHAT EXACTLY IS DEMOCRACY?
PLURALISM IS THE HALLMARK OF IT.
IN A DEMOCRACY, CITIZENS CAN
HAVE ANY OPINION THEY WANT TO
HAVE.
IN THE OPINION THEY WANT IN
PUBLIC WHENEVER THEY CARE TO
DISCUSS IT IN THROUGH MASS
MEDIA.
IF CITIZENS ARE TO SATISFIED
WITH THEIR POLITICAL LEADERSHIP,
THEY CAN CHALLENGE THEIR LEADERS
FOR OFFICE.
ALL OF THESE ARE TRUE IN EVERY
FREE COUNTRY IN EVERY.
ALL
PERIODALWAYS BE THESE ARE PRESSS
FOR DEMOCRACY.
YOU SHOULD KNOW ABOUT A PARTY
THE LARGEST OPPOSITION PARTY IN
THAT COUNTRY.
OVER THE WEEKEND, THE PRESIDENT
OF UKRAINE VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY
BAND OF THAT PARTY.
OPPOSITION PLATFORM FOR LIFE IS
NOT PROHIBITED FROM "ALL
ACTIVITY WITHIN UKRAINE."
WITH A SINGLE COMMAND, ZELENSKYY
MADE IT IMPOSSIBLE FOR ANYONE TO
RUN AGAINST HIM FOR PRESIDENT
BUT HE DID THAT NOT JUST TO
OPPOSITION PLATFORMS, BUT TO TEN
OTHER POLITICAL PARTIES HE
THOUGHT WERE ORIGINALLY LOYAL TO
HIM, THEY ARE ILLEGAL NOW.
THERE'S A WAR UNDERWAY IN
UKRAINE AND ON THE BASIS
ZELENSKYY HAS DECLARED MARTIAL
LAW.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THE
OPPOSITION PARTIES HE BANNED
WERE EVEN IN
AND ITS WAR AGAINST UKRAINE.
DENOUNCE THE
ZELENSKYY TOOK THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TURN UKRAINE INTO EFFECTIVELY
A ONE-PARTY STATE WHICH IT NOW
DEAD.
HAVING BANNED ALL OPPOSITION, HE
SEIZED CONTROL OF THE COUNTRY'S
MEDIA OUTLETS.
ZELENSKYY SIGNED A DEGREE THAT
THE CURRIES ALL TELEVISION
CHANNELS IN A SINGLE PLATFORM
THE CONTROLS.
HE SUPPORTS THIS AS A "UNIFIED
INFORMATION POLICY" AND IT
CERTAINLY IS UNIFIED.
IF THESE DETAILS SEEMS SHOCKING
TO YOU, NOT THE ZELENSKYY YOU
HEARD ABOUT FROM
"THE TODAY SHOW," YOU MIGHT NOT
HAVE BEEN PAYING ATTENTION TO
UKRAINE.
ZELENSKYY HAS BEEN SOLIDIFYING
COMPLETE CONTROL OVER UKRAINE
FOR A LONG TIME, LONG BEFORE THE
RUSSIAN INVASION AND THE WAR.
LAST YEAR, HE MADE HIS POLITICAL
OPPONENT ARRESTED.
AT THE SAME TIME, SPACE A
SHUTDOWN OF THREE OF UKRAINE'S
POPULAR TELEVISION NETWORKS,
CHANNELS NOT COINCIDENTALLY HAD
CRITICIZED HIM.
HOW SHOULD WE AS AMERICANS
ASSESS THIS?
FIRST AND MOST OBVIOUSLY BY
ADMITTING THAT HIS
AUTHORITARIANISM, NOT DEMOCRACY.
SECOND BY ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
ACTUALLY IT'S PRETTY COMMON
AROUND THE WORLD BE EVEN IN
2022, REAL DEMOCRACY IS A RARE
THING ANYWHERE.
MOST COUNTRIES ARE STILL
GOVERNED BY SOME VARIETY OF
DICTATORSHIP, WHATEVER THEY MAY
CALL IT FAIR THAT INCLUDES CLOSE
AMERICAN ALLIES.
THE KINGDOM OF JORDAN AND
SAUDI ARABIA COME TO MIND, BUT
THERE ARE OTHERS.
OTHERS WE PREFERRED DEMOCRACY
EVERYWHERE IN EVERY COUNTRY BUT
AS AMERICANS IT'S PROBABLY A
WASTE OF TIME TO GET TOO
INVOLVED IN THE INTERNAL AFFAIRS
OF OTHER COUNTRIES BEAR THEIR
HEARTS HAVE CHANGED.
WHAT WE CARE ABOUT THEM OF ALL
AMERICANS SHOULD CARE ABOUT IS
WHAT HAPPENS HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THE UNITED STATES IS, DESPITE
THE FACT THAT IT'S ALSO A
BUMPER STICKER FROM DOESN'T MAKE
IT UNTRUE, IS A BEACON OF HOPE
AND FREEDOM TO THE REST OF THE
WORLD BUT HOW DO WE MAINTAIN
THAT INSPIRING POSITION?
BY NOT SIMPLY SETTING PEOPLE
MISSILES BUT BY REMAINING FREE
OURSELVES.
THE UNITED STATES CANNOT BE A
BEACON OF FREEDOM, OF LIGHT IN
THE WORLD, IF WE ARE NOT FREE.
SO THAT'S THE FIRST THING WE DO,
IF WE WANT TO INSPIRE AND CHANGE
THE WORLD, UKRAINE.
MAKE SURE THAT WE STAY FREE.
WITH THAT CONCERN IN MINE, YOU
SHOULD BE VERY WORRIED BY YOUR
LEADERS RESPONSE BY WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN UKRAINE, THE
GROWING DICTATORSHIP THERE.
AND THAT'S A WORD FOR IT.
WHAT'S ANOTHER WORD FOR IT?
IF YOU HAVE IDEAS, SEND IT TO
US.
THE VERY SAME DAY THAT ZELENSKY
SHUT DOWN OPPOSITION MEDIA AND
OPPOSITION POLITICAL PARTIES,
PROFESSIONAL LIAR AND PUNDIT
DAVE AND FROM POSTED THIS ON
TWITTER, "UKRAINE MIGHT BE THE
FOR EXAMPLE IN HUMAN HISTORY
THAT UNDER THE PRESSURE OF WAR
IS BECOMING MORE TOLERANT AND
MORE LIBERAL.
DELMA."
RIGHT.
WHEN YOU UNDERMINE ALL CRITICISM
THAT'S CALLED TOLERANCE,
DEMOCRACY?
DO NOT TAKE THE WORD OF
WARMONGER PROPAGANDA.
ALL OF WASHINGTON IS TELLING YOU
THAT.
WATCH.
>> SO PROUD OF
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY AND THE
COURAGE HE HAS SHOWN AND IN
CONGRESS WE ARE TRYING TO GET
THE ADMINISTRATION ONBOARD.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SHOWING LOWER
LEADERSHIP JUST LIKE
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SHOWED
LAUREL LEADERSHIP.
>> SHOW THE EXAMPLE THAT WE ALL
COULD REACH, A MOMENT OF REAL
TESTING.
>> GOVERNMENT DOESN'T GIVE US
OUR RIGHTS.
OUR RIGHTS COME FROM GOD AND
GOVERNMENT IS JUST A SHARED TOOL
TO SECURE THEM AND YOU SEE THAT
SPIRIT, THE AMERICAN,
PHILADELPHIA 1787 SPIRIT IN
ZELENSKYY RIGHT NOW.
>> Tucker: THESE PEOPLE.
SO THE MAN WHO JUST DECLARED
HIMSELF KING IS ACTUALLY THE
WORLD'S NEWEST
GEORGE WASHINGTON.
OKAY.
SO YOU CAN BE DEEPLY CONCERNED
AND THAT DEEPLY SADDENED,
OUTRAGE, BY WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
UKRAINIANS WITHOUT SAYING THINGS
LIKE THAT.
THIS IS ABSURD.
IT'S A LIE!
THAT'S THE WORD FROM
SENATOR BEN SASSE OF NEBRASKA, A
REPUBLICAN.
AT ONE LEVEL YOU KNOW WHY PEOPLE
ARE WHIPPED INTO AN EMOTIONAL
FRENZY WHEN THEY ARE TALKED
ABOUT UKRAINE BUT RUSSIA'S
INVASION OF UKRAINE WAS
SHOCKING, WRONG, THE SUFFERING
OF CIVILIANS IS HORRIFYING.
IT'S ENTIRELY NATURAL TO WAIT
FOR THE UKRAINIANS TO EXPEL
INVADERS AND OBVIOUSLY WE ARE
ROOTING FOR THEM TO EXPEL THE
INVADERS, RUSSIA.
BUT.
JUST BECAUSE WHAT RUSSIA HAS
DONE IN UKRAINE IS WRONG DOESN'T
MEAN YOU HAVE TO LIE ABOUT THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT.
IN FACT, IF YOU REALLY CARED
ABOUT UKRAINIAN PEOPLE, AND ALL
PEOPLE USE ON TV, "WE CARE SO
MUCH" -- YOU WOULDN'T WANT THEM
TO LIVE UNDER A DICTATOR.
YOU BE HIGHLY UPSET WITH WHAT
ZELENSKYY JUST DID.
EVEN WHEN THEY KNOW BETTER, SOME
ARE TOO DUMB TO KNOW.
BUT BARACK OBAMA'S AMBASSADOR TO
RUSSIA, UNLIKE BEN SASSE,
ACTUALLY UNDERSTANDS EASTERN
EUROPE.
HE HAS LIVED THERE.
HE KNOWS EXACTLY WHO ZELENSKYY
IS AND EXACTLY WHAT HE'S DOING.
HERE'S HIS ASSESSMENT OF THE
UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT, NOT THE
PEOPLE, THE GOVERNMENT OF THIS
AFTERNOON.
"IF ZELENSKYY REMAINS IN POWER,
UKRAINIAN DEMOCRACY IS
PRESERVED."
THAT MAN TEACHES IN STANFORD.
BUT THAT'S NOT TRUE!
UKRAINE WAS INVADED BY ITS
NEIGHBORS IT WE OPPOSE THAT.
WE SHOULD OPPOSE THAT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN UKRAINE IS
A DEMOCRACY.
IT'S NOT.
WE SHOULDN'T TELL AMERICANS IT
IS BECAUSE IT'S ALIVE.
WE SHOULD TELL THE TRUTH.
BUT VIRTUALLY NO ONE IS TELLING
THE TRUTH, EVERYONE IS LYING.
WHY IS EVERYONE -- WHY NOT SAY,
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS THAT RUSSIA DID
THIS AND WE LIKE UKRAINE BETTER.
WHY GO THE EXTRA STEP TO TELL US
THAT UKRAINE IS A MODEL
DEMOCRACY WHEN IT'S NOT AT ALL?
WHY ARE THEY DOING THAT?
MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE UKRAINE
EXACTLY HAS A SORT OF DEMOCRACY
THEY'D LIKE TO SEE IN THE
UNITED STATES.
THEY HATE TO THINK THAT COULD BE
TRUE.
IT'S SCARY TO THINK THAT'S TRUE.
BUT ASK YOURSELF...
PLAY THIS WORD GAME.
IF THEY CAN FIND A "NATIONAL
SECURITY PRETEXT FOR IT," A WAR,
DO YOU THINK ADAM SCHIFF OR
KAMALA HARRIS, OR MITCH
McCONNELL WOULD PAUSE FOR EVEN
A SECOND BEFORE MANNING THEIR
POLITICAL OPPONENTS FOR RUNNING
FOR OFFICE FROM THIS COUNTRY.
WHERE THEY HESITATE BEFORE
PULLING THE SHOW OFF THE AIR
FOREVER?
OF COURSE NOT.
THEY DO IT IN A FLASH.
THEY'D CALL IT "DEMOCRACY."
YOU THINK THESE PEOPLE LOVE
ZELENSKYY NOT BECAUSE HE
REPRESENTS THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE
BUT BECAUSE ZELENSKYY IS EXACTLY
THE LEADER THEY WOULD LIKE TO
BE.
WITH WILDLY EXPANDED WAR POWERS
TO MAKE EVERYONE WHO COMPLAINS
TO SHUT UP AT GUNPOINT BUT MAYBE
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING ON.
IT SEEMS OBVIOUS IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT.
UKRAINE, THEY NEVER HAD THE
POWER TO DO THAT IN THIS
COUNTRY, THE LAST FREE COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD BUT WE SHOULD NOT
LET THEM DO THAT BECAUSE FREEDOM
IN AMERICA IS NOT JUST IMPORTANT
TO US, OUR CHILDREN, OUR
GRANDCHILDREN, IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THE GLOBE.
WE ARE THE LAST FREE COUNTRY.
WE MUST REMAIN FREE.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME, IF WAR IS
BEING WAGE IN AMERICA'S NAME AND
ARM DOWN THE COME IN WITH OUR
MONEY
, THEY ARE AN AWFUL LOT OF
HEROIC CITIZENS ON TELEVISION
BUT HOW IS THE GOVERNMENT BEHAVE
IN QUESTION BUT WE HAVE THE
RIGHT TO KNOW EVEN IF STATE
MEDIA IN UKRAINE WILL REPORT IT,
EVEN IF OUR SORT OF STATE MEDIA
CONTROLLED HERE DOWNPLAYS IT,
DISMISSES IT.
HERE IS A MAN, DREW
'S APPEARED ONCNN.
IN THIS CLIP HE CASUALLY
ANNOUNCES THAT HE'S ORDERED THE
CASTRATION OF CAPTURED RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS.
WATCH.
>> [SPEAKING IN UKRAINIAN]
>> Tucker: "COCKROACHES," NOT
PEOPLE.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THE BROADER
UKRAINIAN JAWS DELMA CAUSES
UNJUST.
IT IS JUST PAY THEY HAVE THE
RIGHT TO FIGHT BACK AND EXPEL
BACK THE RUSSIANS.
WE ARE PAYING FOR THIS BID WE
HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING.
THAT VIDEO, BY THE WAY,
DISAPPEARED, PEOPLE ON THE
INTERNET MANAGED TO GET A COPY
OF IT.
YOU MIGHT HEAR IT DISMISSED AS
RUSSIAN TROPICANA AS HUNTER
BIDEN'S LAPTOP WAS
BUT IT'S NOT RUSSIAN PROPAGANDA.
IT'S REAL.
THE MAN YOU SAW SPEAKING CONFIRM
THE VIDEO IS AUTHENTIC.
HE APOLOGIZED FOR IT.
MURDERING POWs AS A WAR CRIME,
SO IS CASTRATING THEM.
WE AREN'T SHOCKED BY THIS.
ATROCITIES HAPPENED DURING WAR.
EVERY WAR.
ALWAYS COME IN THE MATTER WHAT
THE NEOCONS MAY TELL YOU.
THIS IS A WAR WE ARE PAYING FOR
IT.
THIS IS A WAR WITH MORAL
IMPLICATIONS.
THIS IS A WAR THE WHITE HOUSE IS
INVOLVED IN AT EVERY LEVEL.
SO WHEN THE UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT
DOES SOMETHING, WE HAVE AN
INTEREST IN KNOWING EXACTLY WHAT
IT IS AND WHAT IT MEANS.
BUT MORE THAN ANYTHING, WE HAVE
AN OVERRIDING INTEREST IN THE
MORAL OBLIGATION TO KEEP THE
UNITED STATES FREE.
WHEN YOU SEE THE